تسللت وحدات خاصه اسرائيليه الى هذه
المنطقه من ضاحيه كتابه في مدينه طول كرم
شمالي الضفه الغربيه المحتله حيث قامت
بمحاصيل على وقع ذلك وقعت اشتباكات مسلحه
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وجيش الاحتلال الذي
دفع بال التعزيزات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
الى هذه المنطقه
لمحاصيل حيث بدات الاشتباكات والحصار في
هذه المنطقه وعلى الفور وسط التعزيزات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه لاطباق الخناق على
هذه المنطقه وهذا المنزل حيث تم اغتيال
ثلاثه فلسطينيين حسب وزاره الصحه تم
الاعلان عن استشهاد يوسف علي الخولي 22
عاما وعاهد سليمان موسى 23 عاما وطارق
امجد شاهين
24 عاما في هذه المنطقه هنا بدا الفلسطين
بالوصول الى منزل احد الشهداء تم حصارنا
حوالي 50 دقيقه 45 دقيقه بعد ما طلعنا
تفاجات انه ابني مسجع على الارض يعني
شهيدا من شهداء هذا الوطن الغالي مثله
كمثل ابناء هذا الوطن من غزه من رفح حتى
جنين ولا نقول الا ما يرضي ربنا لله ما
اخذ ولله ما اعطى وكل شيء عنده بمقدار وصل
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي في مدينه طول
جثامين الشهداء الثلاثه تم التعرف على
شهيدين وبعد يعني فتره من الزمن تم التعرف
على الشهيد الثالث نتيجه لدهس من قبل جيب
عسكري اسرائيلي اثناء انسحاب جيش الاحتلال
من المنطقه شلال الدماء لا يكد يتوقف هنا
في الضفه الغربيه على وقع تصعيد اسرائيلي
كبير عم المنطقه يقول المقاومون ان كل
الخيارات اهم مفتوحه لردع الاحتلال ونيل
الحريه ليث جعار
الجزيره من مدينه
طولكرم